gamestop gamestop gamestop this
struggling video game retailers shares
were worth a few dollars in 2020
by january 28 2021 they peaked at over
450 dollars
game stops stock is surging the frenzy
was seemingly caused by a reddit forum
called wall street bets
it has millions of members who hoovered
up shares in gamestop
in what has been touted as a battle
between wall street and vigilante day
traders
who wanted to stick it to the
establishment investors
sending shock waves through wall street
and even raising alarm at the us
treasury
some trading platforms eventually
restricted trading of gamestop shares
what does this reveal about the u.s
stock market
you've submitted your questions and
alice fullwood our wall street
correspondent
and henry kerr our economics editor have
answered them
why did trading platforms like robin
hood restrict people from buying
gamestop shares
the decision that robin had took to halt
trading of gamestop shares has been
extremely controversial so it is worth
digging into sort of why that decision
was taken
um at the moment the sort of likeliest
theory seems that
they were struggling to cope with the
sort of sheer volume and sheer
amount of interest that users of robin
hood had
in gamestop shares um you know there are
estimates out there that half of all of
robin hood's customers had some exposure
to this stock those pressures may have
sort of contributed to robinhood's
decision to halt uh trading but you know
the bigger picture is that although this
sort of one retail brokerage
um one you know made the decision to
halt trading games top shares
that was because it was sort of uniquely
positioned
um and sort of uniquely exposed to the
dynamics in this you know most other
retail brokerages um with the exception
of a couple others
did manage to keep trading and gamestop
shares open because they weren't as
exposed to the dynamics as robin hood
was
what is short selling and what is a
short squeeze
so short selling is where investors bet
against
a stock and the way they do that is by
borrowing the stock selling it and then
hoping to later buy it back for a lower
price
to re to give the stock back to its
original owner and they then pocket the
difference
in the interim if the price falls so
it's just a standard way that investors
would bet on
a stock going down a short squeeze
is when uh it becomes difficult for the
person who shorted the stock
i.e the person who's borrowed and then
sold it to get it back again and the
reason it's difficult is because the
stock has become a lot more expensive uh
in the meantime
so they get squeezed and because if i'm
a short seller i'm contractually obliged
to give back the stock that i borrowed
i essentially have to go into the market
and buy it however high the price has
gone
the only alternative is to breach my
contract or to go bankrupt
so a short squeeze is just when there's
lots of people who have shorted the
stock
and the price of that stock goes up a
lot and it becomes hard for the shorts
to get out of their trade
and that's precisely what's happened in
the case of gamestop has gamestop
shown there's one rule for wall street
and another for ordinary people
inevitably yes because the
you know hedge funds who operate every
day on wall street and have massive
uh amounts of uh uh cash and have
massive to cash to invest and have all
the best software and platforms and
connections and terminals and all these
things
you're never going to be able to match
that as a retail investor sitting at
home
so it's inevitable there's going to be
an asymmetry there uh the more
controversial edge to that question
is whether or not uh regulators or
the system is in some sense conspiring
against the retail investors
which i think is what people on the
forum would would tell you
now it's true that regulators are much
more likely to take a
paternalistic stance towards retail
investors than they would towards
hedge funds i don't think regulators
really worry that much about
hedge funds uh losing money unless
there's some sort of systemic threat to
the system
whereas historically regulators have
cared quite a lot about the idea that
retail investors
know what they're doing when they get
into markets now of course there are a
lot of people
uh in the current situation who are
buying gamestop shares who say we know
exactly what we're doing and this is all
a ruse
saying that we don't trying to protect
us from ourselves to actually
keep us out of this market which we're
revolutionizing but the thing is it's
got so vile now that of course there
will be people who don't
and i think regulators will be
interested in that it is interesting
um in the context of sort of how much
access retail investors have now though
compared with what they used to have in
the past
you know there's so much direct access
the sort of
the fact that it's frictionless now
whereas you used to have to pay trading
fees
um how much information um is accessible
sort of online and can be shared
you know between sort of regular
investors um
this is um and it can be hard to see
this at the moment sort of
the most um probably the most equal it's
ever been
between wall street and ordinary people
you shouldn't sort of lose sight of the
fact that
actually now is sort of a a period of
sort of
great access of regular investors that
contrasts with
how things used to be it is the case
that short selling
uh in the market generally is something
that aids
price discovery it it helps the market
function and work out what prices should
be
weren't the case that short selling now
always came with the risk that you'd
sort of become an internet meme and have
loads of people come in and buy the
stock to implement a short squeeze
you might see that as a bad thing for
markets for price discovery generally
however because what's happened with
gamestop is so unique
in so far as the shorts positions were
so large relative to the liquidity of
the trading
it's unlikely really that that will be
repeated again but it's interesting that
a lot of what's going on
is uh people writing online that these
short sellers are sort of
you know bad actors for having sold the
stock short
uh especially during a economic downturn
like when we're in
yeah short sellers are you they're easy
to villainize but they
they are not necessarily always the
villains how have the authorities
reacted
should the situation be regulated
there's definitely a sense from some
politicians
and um kind of across the spectrum
really
um that it was not legitimate for for
robin hood to have uh hold the trading
in the way that they did
um i think that that uh case is going to
or that argument is going to struggle a
lot um based on sort of terms of service
and laws as they're currently in place
there's also been this sort of broader
discussion i guess
of whether or not retail investors
should have sort of as much
access and and should be able to trade
sort of all the
the highly leveraged derivatives and
things that they are trading
um that's a debate that sort of is a
turtle of wall street
and eternal with markets regulators what
does gamestop tell us about the state of
the us stock market
is it overheated there's a sense in
which what's going on with gamestop
is an isolated phenomenon and it's
actually small relative to the market at
large
but you could you know the short squeeze
the
uh what's going on with the uh options
trading which sort of
has these momentum effects uh driving
one's stock up very
high it has had spillover effects but in
general i would view the gamestop thing
as an isolated phenomenon
now of course some people say can't you
look at what's going on here which is
a lot of everyday investors sitting at
home punting on the
stock market and doesn't that tell you
something generally about the kind of
economic situation we're in
my take on that would be that the easy
money is a response to the economic
circumstance and high asset prices are a
natural consequence
and it doesn't have to be a bubble for
that to be true but it is the case that
i don't think this could have happened a
year ago
without the amount of liquidity uh in
the system and without the amount
of money in people's bank accounts as a
result of
the stimulus measures in response to the
pandemic
so if you were someone who believed that
the stock market is a massive bubble
this is a sort of string to the bow of
your argument because you can say look
isn't it always the case in history that
stock market bubbles were
accompanied by these kind of mad pockets
of exuberance and isn't that what we're
seeing here
i think i'd argue that what we're really
seeing here is a sort of
new phenomenon about uh the internet
ganging up against the establishment and
using financial markets to do so and
that's not something we've really seen
before there'll be a lot of
um sort of digging into that point uh to
really try and find out sort of how much
um was driven by initially sort of
retail exuberance but what role
other factors played whether it's this
sort of derivatives um uh trading
whether it's the
short squeeze or whether it's sort of
big institutions piling in right now the
sort of story is that oh it's all the
retail investors against the hedge funds
but it may turn out that a lot of hedge
funds were on the same side as the
retail investors all along
and that they were sort of a big factor
in driving that stock as well but i do
think that it's kind of interesting that
we've gone from
um sort of worrying about bubbles in in
companies that that
you know you might think would do well
in the pandemic the big tech stocks um
and now this sort of form has turned its
attention on the sort of really
unloved value companies you know cinema
chains blackberry nokia
um gamestop etc you know all of these
firms
um are sort of the the reverse trade of
the bubble trade almost because they
were they're sort of um their business
models and their sort of
uh evaluations were so depressed
actually before this this happened so i
i do think that it's sort of slightly
different from that
that dynamic it's that's really
interesting point about the
uh hedge funds interest now in the web
forums because of course that
is what you'd expect not only if you're
an investor who wants to know where
markets are going to go
would you be on the lookout for these
sorts of phenomena uh if you were
someone who potentially wanted to
manipulate the market you might try and
start your own you know meme on wall
street bets for one of these stocks
having invested in it
uh in a sort of classic pump and dump
scheme so i would have thought that
after this whole
thing is over there'll be quite a lot of
uh interest
in the form by investors and also
potentially uh
some some bad actors might see it as an
opportunity
to to try and manipulate the market has
gamestop
started a trend will this happen to
other companies shares
i mean i would fully expect that
something similar might happen to other
companies shares
uh insofar as i think the
widespread retail access to financial
markets
are here to stay i think that uh you
know
reddit's here to stay these social media
dynamics are here to stay
the sort of slightly populist dynamics
of what's going on
are going to be around for a while
they're a feature of
how society is at the moment i do think
gamestop was uniquely
uh positioned for this to happen in
terms of as i've said before in terms of
the amount of short interest
and uh the the sort of thin trading in
the underlying shares
uh so i'd be surprised if we saw
anything as remarkable quite as
remarkable as this happen
again but i think that you know these
retail traders are going to be an
ongoing force in the markets yes
i'm alice forward the economist wall
street correspondent you can read more
of my analysis of the game stock story
and its implications by clicking the
link
and please don't forget to subscribe